now we will get to the formal stuff of
algebra soon the algebra is really just
about a special way of working with
numbers so we want to know how to work
with numbers but first before we get to
talk about and that's what very
meticulous
this makes just math counting
cooperation and numbers so I'm going to
give you two laws today I will give you
a third one tomorrow and explain what
they are so that when you see them with
numbers they'll make sense once we go
okay so the first law is called their
commutator board it's got a big scary
name commutative law but it's actually a
really simple idea if you got some
colored pens or pencils or protectors
again we're going to illustrate this
very simply I'm commuting your parents I
commuted to a city for a long time for
well university that can be community
just means changing place from one place
to another I used to be over there and
now when we talk about number this
community means by changing their order
it's like it used to be like here here
yeah and then I kind of rearrange them
just like you rearranged so I'd like you
to draw it for me okay we're gonna do
some counters in Guha right and you can
see here if I said here's a color if I
said three he's like three I don't know
what if you want them to be baubles
coins M&Ms something like that if I say
three plus five
yeah we all know what three plus five is
I'm gonna put them all in a big pile
over here one two three four five six
seven eight
done okay three plus five equals eight
however and watch this mark this just
keep your eyes on this for a second if I
commuted these marbles pennies image
whatever they are change their positions
a little bit if I move two of them from
here to here is the statement still true
it is still true right five plus three
is still eight you still got the same in
this case I can commute these numbers
and then find they still end up the same
so let's write this example for example
right the first thing we work was three
plus five and we've got a number out
right we have just noticed that if you
change the order of those numbers hey
and up the same three plus five five is
three same result yeah are you with me
so addition it's commutated
it can change its oil cool
okay so in fact that's a great idea
let's just write this okay this is that
addition except addition is commutator
you can add the order you can add the
numbers in whatever order you like and
you get the same result okay now
additions not the only operation where
you can change the order and you get the
same thing yes we are joining suggests
yeah yeah go ahead
okay multiplication is also commutator
and he's home gonna illustrating okay
I'm what divisions all that groups right
like if I said it's better three plus
five if I said three times five okay
three times five is three groups of five
yeah so I totally going through all of
this hmm he's so I'm gonna do it
remember how I was doing the fractions
before and had some boxes you do boxing
against if you got a rollup this might
help we're going to do like this let's
divide this one
yes subtractions interestingly yes a
nerd yes sooner I think you're on the
right track you do know it's additional
application and do tend to make numbers
bigger however and I'm just going to try
to teach this right what about this
don't answer this question just think
about it I think I think this on the
board division thank you yeah well I'm
just gonna leave that like that right
now that's actually is that division
isn't multiplication don't you know you
think about it right can I can I change
these I'm gonna miss getting bigger or
smaller we have a think about it all
right now
he's my grid this is called in the rain
okay I mean if you recall is there I've
got here three across
and I've got five down okay so I can
split this up into three groups of five
do you notice that one group two groups
three groups
yeah so therefore I can say three times
five and we know it three times five
heads you can just count them out one
two three four five six seven all the
way up until 15 okay but just like I can
make three groups of five that's by
looking at the columns you can just as
easily see I can make five groups of
three how do I do that on here instead
of video columns what should I do cally
yes
yeah I'm gonna go for rows right that's
what they will give me three six nine
and I'll still get to the same thing
right so 3 times 5 5 times 3 3 groups of
five 5 groups of three they are the same
right yesterday so just call me tell you
is it question two different numbers
where you can switch them around it'll
do the same awesome that's exactly right
that's exactly right so if you're adding
anything you can swim okay before we
write down the same thing for
multiplication I'm now going to look at
this example right what would this mean
no this was an example what about
another reason what would this mean
remember I said this means three groups
of five what does this how would you
explain that to someone yeah
okay almost a few 10/2 yeah good good
good
so I'm going to write this verse as 10
times 10 times but because
multiplication I can you can see I can
switch the order right it's the same as
saying 1/2 times Tim how would I read
that I wouldn't say 10 hearts would i
I'd say half off Tim yeah okay so that
you could even draw a diagram for this
but it would take us a while because I
chose to be there
okay so again just like addition
multiplication is commutated
okay so remember commute commuting is
that changing order right and addition
to multiplication you can do it I'm not
going to demonstrate for you but you can
see doesn't work for the other
operations neither does it right what
are the operations that we already know
populations yeah subtraction good yeah
subtractions emphasis of this one five
take away three would be to two but
three take away five yeah we've learned
about integers right so something else
and it's the same to your fourth
division you're gonna get different easy
features